in this video we continue our
exploration of quantities of interest
associated with the short-term behavior
of Markov chain
this time we suppose that we have a
Markov chain composed of a single
recurrent class such as this one here we
have our recurrent class and these are
transient States we also assume that we
are interesting in a specific recurrent
State let's say nine so this is my state
s and we will assume that the Markov
chains start from a given initial state
state I and assume that I is one now the
question we ask is given that you
started in one house is it going to take
to reach nine for the first time we know
this is a recurrent class so we know
that the Markov chain eventually will
come to that class and circulate here so
you know that the Markov chain will get
to that state nine you are interested in
knowing when it does so for the first
time of course we don't know for sure
this is random it is a random variable
and let's try to calculate the expected
value of this random variable more
precisely this is what we would like to
do we would like to find the mean first
passage time from I to s from any
starting state i here we're going to
illustrate that with 1 and
mathematically this is what we have here
so here again what you have is that the
Markov chain started in state I at time
0 and now you are looking at this set
here and this set records all the time n
such that your Markov chain xn is in the
state s of interest so out of this set
you are looking at the minimum and that
verifies that so this is going to be a
random variable and you take the
expected value of that and this is what
we call the mean first passage time from
I to s again this is the expected number
of steps in order to get from I to s for
the first time
so how do we go about calculating such a
quantity well let us think a little bit
we are looking at the events that you
will visit nine from one for the first
time what happened after visiting nine
is of no relevance in our calculation in
other words our calculation will never
involve this arc and will not involve
this art either because in order for the
Markov chain to traverse this arc or
this one it would have to visit nine
first so what it means is that we can
forget about this arc and we can forget
about this arc in a sense that they
don't matter in the calculation of the
mean first passage time to s now
removing these arcs entirely means that
you would have to increase the
probability of that cell transition from
zero to two one so what do you get
well you get this following graph we
have removed this arcs and we have
increased the priority 0.2 here to 1 and
again we have argued that calculating
the mean first passage time from I to s
in this graph is the same as doing the
same thing for this graph but here we
have a very special structure we have
only one recurrent state left which is
state 9 and that state is an absorbing
state all the other state this one was
transient transient transient this one
becomes a transient state and this one
is also a transient state in this new
transition priority diagram so we get a
situation where we have one single
absorbing state and we are interested in
calculating the priority starting from I
to reach that absorbing state and also
the number of steps it takes to do that
which is what we did in the previous
video so let us repeat what we had seen
before so this is going to be the unique
solution to this system T of s equals 0
of course since you start from s you are
in s and so that not in the matter
time it takes to get to s is zero and
otherwise for all the other states that
are not s this is the resulting system
of equation that we have and the unique
solution of this system gives you the
result of finding the expected amount of
time to go to the absorbing state s so
using this simple trick we have been
able to use the previous calculation to
calculate something else let us consider
a belated question which we call the
mean recurrence time of s here let's go
back to the original graph and this is
our state s and now the question is the
following given that you are in S what
is the amount of time it will take for
the Markov chain to return to s for the
first time so for this question the
Markov chain is currently in nine and
you ask yourself how long is it going to
take once you leave nine to return to
nine here again we don't know for sure
it's a random variable and we are
interested in the expectation of that
random variable in other words in the
expected number of steps it takes in
order to get back to nine once you are
in nine and this is what we mean by the
mean recurrence time of s and
mathematically this is what it is it is
almost the same formula as the one that
you had here except that here you have n
greater than equals to one as opposed to
n greater than equal to zero it simply
means that you are not interested in the
first time that joini is because you
start from s so you want to have and
greater than equals to one N equals zero
that work tsf star would have been zero
so how would you solve that problem well
here again you use the same trick that
we use before and think in terms of tree
let's look at the mock of chain in state
nine what can happen next from nine it
can go to three
or it can go to five or it can jump on
itself so this is what the part is you
point to this is where the priority 0.2
and this is who the priority of 0.6 and
now after you make one transition so
that you are in three now what is the
time to get to nine
well it's exactly T three where the T is
the solution here of that previous
system what about from 5g5
and what about from nine forty nine
ninety nine was zero so from that tree
what you have is T nine star will be
zero point two times T three plus zero
point six times T five plus zero point
two times T 9 plus of course one because
you have done one transition where again
this value of T three T 5 and T nine are
the one corresponding to this solution
here so of course T nine is zero so what
we have shown here that in general this
is actually what you would have and this
is exactly what we have written here TS
f star is one plus the summation of PS G
of T of G where T of j is the solution
to this system so again you start from
nine you have to do a transition first
you can do a transition onto yourself
you can go to three or you can go to six
after that transition which counts for
the number one here what happened is you
are trying to find the solution to this
system which is the mean first passage
time from the current state where you
are to nine and then when you put these
two things together will you get the
mean recurrence time of
9